a second set of human remains were found
at lake mead yesterday this comes less
than a week after a man's body was found
in a barrel on the lake shore decades
after police believe he was murdered
madison kimbrough joins us in the
newsroom with the latest in this latest
investigation madison i spoke with two
sisters who made this startling
discovery saturday afternoon along with
a retired henderson police officer who
is offering these women and anyone else
who finds additional remains a
5-thousand dollar reward
two bodies found in less than a week at
lake mead the first discovered in a
barrel and the second found saturday
afternoon in the sand at caulville bay
henderson locals lindsay melvin and her
sister lynette were paddle boarding when
they made the discovery at first i
thought it was a big horn sheep and we
kind of started digging around a little
bit as we discovered the jaw we realized
it was human remains and that's when we
contacted park rangers to come and
investigate for the longest time i was
in disbelief like i did not think that
we actually just came upon human remains
i thought that i was like this has to be
rocks this is still rocks it's rocks
nope it's definitely remains as of now
the clark county coroner's office is
working to identify the remains retired
henderson police officer david colemeyer
has been invested in what's been going
on and wanted to do something to help he
and his partner decided they would offer
a 5-thousand dollar reward to those who
find additional bodies at the lake he
says with this incentive he hopes it
will bring a sense of closure to the
families and friends of these victims
while assisting local law enforcement in
their efforts now it makes you start
thinking right like how many other
bodies will be recovered my feeling with
this particular situation it could be
more of a drowning person i think it's
not related to
the situation with the barrel but
definitely
something of major interest would be
nice to identify who this person is cole
meyer has currently set up a gofundme
page where people can donate funds to
help with burials
and we will have a contact for cole
meyer up on our website at 8newsnow.com
now as for saturday's finding sources
tell the 8 news now i-team there are no
signs of foul play and at this point
metro police are not involved in the
investigation live in the newsroom
madison kimbrough live local now